안녕하세요, 제 이름은 Olivia Lan이고 IBM Quantum의 연구원이자 교육자예요. 이 영상은
Qiskit YouTube 채널과 저희 학습 플랫폼에서 새롭게 시작하는 시리즈의 출발점이에요. 시리즈 이름은 '실전 Quantum Computing'이에요.
간단히 말하면, 이 시리즈에서는 지금 실제로 존재하는 양자 컴퓨터를 최대한 활용하는 방법을 알려드릴 거예요.
인터넷에는 이미 양자 컴퓨터와 미래 가능성, 또는 양자 계산의 이론적 개념에 관한 영상이 수십억 개나 있어요.
물론 그런 내용도 똑같이 중요해요. 예를 들어 John Watrous가 진행하는 '양자 정보와 계산 이해하기'도 있죠.
하지만 이 강좌에서는 수강생이 이전보다 조금 더 많은 배경 지식을 가지고 있다고 가정하고,
기술적으로 굉장히 깊이 들어갈 거예요. 지난 한 해 동안,
그리고 이 영상을 녹화하는 2024년 현재, 우리는 새로운 계산의 시대로 넘어가는 전환점을 목격하고 있어요.
양자 컴퓨터가 드디어 실제로 유용해질 수 있는 지점에 다가오고 있어요. 소규모 circuit과 양자 컴퓨터로 실험하는 것이
커뮤니티에 이 기계를 활용하는 방법을 교육하는 데 필요했지만, 당시에는 일반 고전 컴퓨터로도 할 수 있는 실험만 하고 있었어요.
하지만 오늘날 우리는 양자 유용성의 시대에 들어섰어요.
그럼 유용성이란 무엇일까요? 이건 양자 우위와는 달라요. 양자 우위는
양자 컴퓨터가 의미 있는 과제에서 고전 컴퓨터를 능가하는 시점을 말해요. 반면 유용성이란
서로 경쟁할 수 있게 되는 것을 의미하고, 이것이 기술 발전의 자연스러운 다음 단계예요.
IBM이 작년에 발표한 논문에서 처음으로 양자 컴퓨터가 물리 모델을 시뮬레이션하고
최첨단 고전 시뮬레이션 기법과 경쟁할 수 있다는 걸 보여줬어요. 심지어
브루트 포스 방식보다도 나은 결과를 내서, 연구자들에게 새로운 연구 방향을 열어줬어요. 왜 이게 지금
일어나고 있냐고요? 지난 몇 달 사이 IBM이 100 qubit 이상의 양자 프로세서를 널리 공개했거든요.
이미 사용자라면, 더 큰 칩을 위한 공간을 만들기 위해 소형 프로세서를 많이 내린 걸 눈치채셨을 거예요. 저희는 이게 정말
중요하다고 생각했어요. 왜냐면 일부 qubit 수는 여전히 고전적으로 시뮬레이션이 가능하기 때문에
그런 칩을 쓸 실질적인 이점이 없거든요. 하지만 100 qubit에서는 더 이상 그렇지 않아요. 고전적으로
시뮬레이션이 불가능해요. 또 한 가지 중요한 점은, 시뮬레이터라는 게 있는데
이건 기본적으로 컴퓨터 프로그램이고, 노이즈를 포함한 양자 시스템의 일부 동작을 흉내낼 수 있어요. 하지만
제가 '흉내낸다'고 했다는 점을 놓치지 마세요. 시뮬레이터는 양자 컴퓨터가 아니에요. 이 규모에서 양자 컴퓨터가 낼 수 있는 결과를
시뮬레이터는 낼 수 없어요. 그래도 테스트 워크플로에서 여전히 중요한 역할을 해요. 이 슬라이드 상단의
질문에 대한 꽤 긴 답이었네요. 실용적인 Quantum Computing이란 무엇인가요? 이 강좌에서 현실적인
양자 활용 사례와 더 큰 규모의 프로세서에서 실험하고 실행하는 모범 사례를 알려드릴 거예요.
그러면 이 강좌는 누구를 위한 걸까요? 레벨 설정부터 시작해 볼게요.
이 강좌는 양자 컴퓨터용 새로운 애플리케이션을 개발하고 싶거나,
현재 작업을 확장하거나 기존 워크플로에 양자를 통합하는 방법을 배우고 싶은 모든 분을 위한 거예요. 앞서
말씀드렸듯이 이 강좌는 실습 위주이고 이론적인 부분은 많이 다루지 않을 거예요.
양자 계산이 무엇인지에 대한 기본적인 이해를 갖고 오시길 바라는데, 아직 거기까지 안 되셨다면 괜찮아요. John Watrous의 강좌
처음 몇 에피소드만 보시면 준비가 될 거예요. 또 시청자분들께서 알아두셨으면 하는 게 있어요.
이 강좌는 물리학자나 컴퓨터 과학자만을 위한 게 아니에요. 이 두 분야가
지난 10여 년간 Quantum Computing을 거의 독점해 왔는데, 빅데이터나
시뮬레이션을 다루는 엔지니어, 화학자, 재료 과학자분들도 이 강좌가 여러분을 위한 것임을 알아주셨으면 해요. 요약하자면
이 강좌는 폭넓은 청중을 대상으로 하고 있고, 전체 과정을 함께해 주시길 바라요. 강좌를 마치면
Qiskit runtime을 통해 유틸리티 규모의 작업을 생성하고 실행하는 방법을 전체 워크플로를 포함해 이해할 수 있게 돼요.
주요 오류 완화 유형을 이해하고 단기적으로 유망한 응용 분야도 파악할 수 있어요. 또한
Qiskit으로 이런 알고리즘들을 모두 실행하고, 마지막으로 노이즈를 이해하고 어떻게 다루는지도 알 수 있게 될 거예요.
자, 시작해 볼게요! Quantum Computing은 개발 초기 단계의 흥미로운 신기술이지만,
수천 년을 거슬러 올라가는 계산의 역사에서 하나의 챕터에 불과해요. 이런
맥락을 이해하는 게 중요하다고 생각해요. 우리가 목표로 하는 것이 좀 더 직관적이고 예측 가능하며 덜
SF처럼 느껴지게 해주거든요. 고대부터 인간은 계산을 수행해야 했어요.
다시 말해, 일정한 규칙과 제약에 따라 정보를 처리해야 했어요.
의사소통, 건설, 상업, 과학, 그리고 삶의 모든 측면을 가능하게 하기 위해서요. 우리는 물리 세계에서
도움을 구했고, 탁월한 발견들을 통해 계산을 돕는 장치들을 만들어냈어요. 오래전 장치들은
나무, 뼈, 매듭 지은 밧줄로 만들어졌고, 지금과는 매우 다른 방식으로 정보를 저장하고 계산을 도왔어요.
레버, 기어, 기타 기계 장치로 만든 기계식 장치들은 초기 천문 시계에서
계산기를 거쳐, 바퀴와 회전 디스크로 방정식을 푸는 미분 분석기 같은 정교한 컴퓨팅 장치로 발전했어요.
문자 기술조차도 이 역사에서 중요한 역할을 했는데, 사람들이 그렇지 않으면
할 수 없었을 계산을 가능하게 해줬기 때문이에요. 오늘날 컴퓨터라고 하면 보통
전자 디지털 컴퓨터를 떠올리지만, 이건 사실 꽤 최근의 기술이에요. 전자 디지털 컴퓨터는
1940년대에 처음 만들어졌어요. 계산을 위한 가장 오래된 도구는 수메르의 주판으로,
전문가들은 기원전 2700~2300년경 바빌론에서 발명됐다고 봐요. 정말
오래전이네요. 하지만 Archimedes부터 Euclid를 거쳐
Einstein에 이르기까지 자연 세계에 대한 이해가 깊어지면서, 더 많은 계산 자원에 대한 수요가 폭발적으로 증가했어요. 오늘날엔 슈퍼컴퓨터가 있는데,
이건 기본적으로 매우 강력한 컴퓨터 여러 대를 병렬로 연결한 거예요. 인류가 가진
어려운 문제를 푸는 최고의 도구 중 하나지만, 이 거대한 컴퓨터들조차 영원히 풀 수 없는 문제들이 여전히 많아요.
이 부분은 나중에 더 다룰게요. 인간이 수천 년 동안 계산을 위해 물리학과 자연을 활용해 왔다는 걸 확인했고,
더 크고 많은 것을 계산하려는 끝없는 탐구를 계속해 왔다는 것도요. 이미 짐작하실 수도 있겠지만,
무어의 법칙에 대해 이미 알고 계실 수도 있어요. 사실 이건 법칙이라기보다는 하나의 관찰이에요. '법칙'이라는 말은 제 생각엔 좀 농담 같은 표현이에요.
집적 회로, 즉 컴퓨터 칩 안의 트랜지스터 최대 개수가
약 2년마다 두 배씩 늘어난다는 거예요. 지난 약 50년간 우리는 이걸 관찰했을 뿐만 아니라 잘 활용해 왔어요.
트랜지스터가 많아질수록 더 빠르고 많은 계산을 할 수 있어요. 이게 본질적으로
컴퓨터가 시간이 지날수록 더 강력해지고 작아진 이유예요. 하지만 나쁜 소식이 있어요. 무어의 법칙이 죽어가고 있어요.
무어의 법칙이 언제 끝날지에 대해 전문가들의 의견이 엇갈리지만, 이미 끝났다고 말하는 사람들도 있어요. 정확히 언제
한계에 도달할지는 모르지만, 결국 불가피하다는 건 알아요. 트랜지스터의 일부 부품이
물리적으로 더 이상 작아질 수 없기 때문이에요. 예를 들어 원자보다 작은 트랜지스터는 만들 수 없잖아요.
물론 이건 물리적으로 완전히 불가능한 얘기예요. 우스운 것 같지만, 이게 바로 우리가 실제로 맞닥뜨린 한계예요. 그러면
그냥 포기하고 "이게 최선이야"라고 할까요? 아니죠, 인간은 절대 그런 적이 없어요. 다행히 양자
역학이 대화에 등장했어요. 양자 역학은 1920년대에 발견됐고, 그 이후로 세상은
말 그대로 완전히 달라졌어요. 그때 이뤄진 혁명적인 발견들에 대해 몇 시간도 이야기할 수 있지만,
이 강좌의 핵심은 그게 아니에요. 대신 양자
역학과 컴퓨팅이 이미 서로 양립할 수 있다는 걸 분명히 짚고 싶어요. 양자 역학에서 얻은
자연에 대한 발견과 이해가 오늘날의 컴퓨터를 가능하게 하는 데 일부 역할을 했어요. 양자
역학 없이는 솔리드 스테이트 하드 드라이브를 이해하거나 발명조차 못 했을 거예요.
Quantum computation은 이 진화의 자연스러운 다음 단계예요.
하지만 계산은 진공 속에 존재하지 않아요. 정보에는 매체가 필요해요.
정보를 계산하는 것은 물리 세계를 활용하고 또 그것에 영향을 미쳐요. 이것이 물리적으로 가능한 것에
한계를 두지만, 자연과 물리적 한계를 이해하는 것이 바로 물리학이라는 학문의 목표이기도 해요.
그래서 어떤 의미에서 물리학과 계산은 항상 서로 얽혀 있었어요. 컴퓨터 과학자이자 IBM 연구원이었던 Ralph Landauer는
수십 년 전에 정보는 물리적이라는 것을 인식했어요. 달리 말하면, 정보는
추상적인 실체가 아니라 물리적 표현을 통해서만 존재한다는 거예요. Landauer의 원리는
정보와 열역학 법칙 사이의 연결고리를 확립해요. 실제로 물리학과
계산 사이에는 많은 연결고리가 있어요. 최근까지 우리가 탐구할 수 있었던 건 고전 물리학뿐이었지만, 양자
역학의 발견으로 이제 완전히 새로운 방식으로 계산할 수 있는 시대의 문턱에 서 있어요. 이게 정말 좋은 이유는
고전 컴퓨터는 자연에서 실제로 일어나는 것을 근사치로만 계산할 수 있고, 어떤 경우엔 그 근사가 매우
제한적이기 때문이에요. 고전 물리학의 법칙을 따르는 기계가
양자 물리학의 법칙을 근사하게 만드는 건 정말 어렵거든요. 자연은 고전적이 아니라 양자적이에요. 이해를 돕는 비유로
풍동을 생각해 볼 수 있어요. 유체 역학은 수학적으로 시뮬레이션하고 예측하기가 굉장히 어렵기로 유명해요.
바람 속을 달리는 자동차처럼 평범한 것조차도요. 자동차 제조사들은 자동차를 설계할 때
이 물리적 상호작용을 시뮬레이션하려고 하면 너무 비용이 많이 들고 비현실적이라는 걸 발견했어요. 그래서
실제로 바람을 불어넣는 터널을 만들어서 차를 그 안으로 몰고 들어가
어떻게 되는지 확인하는 방법을 택했어요. 이게 제가 고전 컴퓨터가 자연을 형편없이
근사할 뿐이라고 할 때의 비유예요. 바람을 시뮬레이션하는 대신
연구자들이 그냥 바람을 재현하는 것처럼, 양자 컴퓨터도 분자 수준에서 자연의 법칙을 근사할 필요가 없어요.
그 법칙을 본질적으로 따르기 때문이에요. 시뮬레이션이 아니라 에뮬레이션이에요. 배터리나 화학 반응을 시뮬레이션할 때도
똑같은 어려움이 생겨요. 이게 다음 섹션으로 이어지는데,
Quantum Computing은 무엇에 유용한가예요.
왜 양자 역학과 컴퓨팅을 결합하려는 걸까요? 이미 최첨단 슈퍼컴퓨터조차
풀기엔 너무 어렵고 계산 비용이 너무 많이 드는 문제들이 있어요.
연구자들만 집중하는 문제처럼 보일 수 있지만, 그 영향은 전 세계에 미칠 수 있어요.
고전 컴퓨터가 막히는 이런 문제들은, 우리 사회가 기술에 점점 더 의존하게 되고
배터리 효율, 금융 모델링, 최적화 같이 진정으로 중요하게 여기는 분야와 관련이 있어요.
그리고 더 나은 비행기를 만드는 방법도요. 양자 컴퓨터로 눈을 돌리는 이유는, 여기에 엄청난 잠재력이 있고
가장 강력한 슈퍼컴퓨터조차 닿을 수 없는 새로운 계산의 문을 열 수 있다고 믿을 만한 충분한 이유가 있기 때문이에요.
이론적으로 일부 양자 알고리즘은 특정 응용 분야에서 최선의 고전 알고리즘보다 우위를 제공해요.
다른 응용 분야에서는, 노이즈와 불완전함이 있더라도 양자 컴퓨터가 고전적인 브루트
포스 솔루션과 경쟁하는 도구로 사용될 수 있다는 증거가 점점 쌓이고 있어요.
기본적으로 완전히 새로운 도구이고, 이걸로 더 멋진 것들을 할 수 있는 방법을 찾고 싶어요. 또한
Feynman이 처음 제안한 아이디어, 즉 물리학과 자연 자체를 이해하는 데 활용하는 것도 생각해볼 수 있어요.
결국 자연은 고전적이 아니라 양자적이라고 이미 말씀드렸잖아요. 이 분야는 믿을 수 없을 만큼 풍부하고 매혹적이며
학제간이에요. 물리학, 컴퓨터 과학, 정보 처리, 그리고 물론 우리가 관심 갖는 특정 응용 분야들을 한데 아우르죠.
하지만 고전 컴퓨터와 달리, 모든 사람이 주머니 속에 양자 컴퓨터를 가지고 다니진 않아요.
아주 최근까지도, 양자 컴퓨터를 실험하려면 직접 만들고 유지보수해야 했어요.
보통 대학교나 연구 시설의 지하 실험실에서요. 제가 잘 알고 있어요. 하지만 이제는 그렇지 않아요.
2016년에 IBM이 최초의 양자 프로세서를 클라우드에 올렸어요. 당시엔 qubit이 5개뿐이었고
오류율도 꽤 높았지만, 그게 불과 8년 전이에요. 지금 얼마나 많이 발전했는지 보세요. 오늘날 우리의 현황은 어떨까요?
현대 컴퓨터 초창기와 비교할 수 있는 점이 많아요. 말씀드렸듯이 이건 매우
어려운 도전이고, 최첨단 연구소나 시설에서 일하는 사람들 외에는
양자 컴퓨터가 널리 보급된 지 불과 8년밖에 안 됐어요. 하지만 그 8년 동안 모든 면에서 발전을 이뤄왔어요.
프로세서는 qubit 수 기준으로 몇 자릿수나 더 커졌고, gate도 크게 개선됐으며, 오류를 줄이거나 완화하는 방법도 도입됐어요.
양자 시스템 고유의 오류를 줄이면서도 결함 허용
양자 컴퓨터를 만들어가고 있어요. 이제 여러분을 포함한 누구나 클라우드에서 호스팅되는 IBM Quantum 프로세서 중 하나를 사용할 수 있고,
그 대부분이 100 qubit 이상을 갖춘 가장 최신의 최고 시스템이에요.
하지만 중요한 건 프로세서의 크기만이 아니에요. 이건 저희가 신경 쓰는 여러 지표 중 하나일 뿐이에요.
물론 qubit이 많으면 더 좋죠. qubit 수가 늘어나도
성능이 떨어지지 않는다면요. 하지만 항상 그런 건 아니에요. 우리는 서로
원치 않을 때 크로스톡으로 간섭하지 않는 고품질 qubit이 더 많이 필요해요. qubit들이 어떻게 서로 연결돼 있는지도 중요한 요소예요.
초전도 circuit에서는 qubit을 물리적으로 어떻게 연결할지가 과제예요. 또 다른 매우 중요한 지표는
2-qubit gate 충실도예요. 단일 qubit에서 실행되는 gate는 오류에 덜 취약하지만, 2-qubit gate는
훨씬 더 큰 문제 영역이에요. 성능이 시간이 지남에 따라 개선되고 있는지 확인하는 주요 지표 중 하나이기도 해요.
2-qubit gate를 제대로 만드는 것이 중요한 이유는, qubit 간 얽힘을 만들어내는 역할을 하기 때문이에요.
얽힘은 양자 컴퓨터에 힘을 부여하는 물리 현상 중 하나예요. 마지막으로 속도와 효율성을 봐요.
양자 칩에서 프로그램을 실행하는 데 걸리는 시간이 최대한 빠르고 효율적으로
이뤄져야 해요. 이 세 가지 지표를 합쳐서 스케일, 품질,
속도라고 부르고, 모두 성능 향상에 필수적이에요. 이제 제가 말씀드린 기술이 실제로 빠르게 발전하고 있다는 걸
뒷받침하는 그래프를 몇 가지 보여드릴게요. qubit 수 자체는 가장 이해하기 쉬운 지표예요.
IBM은 향후 몇 년간 qubit 수와 프로세서 크기 목표에 대한 로드맵을 공개했어요.
이 영상을 촬영하는 2024년 기준으로, Heron과 Condor 프로세서로 로드맵에 딱 맞게 진행 중이에요.
다음은 품질이에요. 이 그래프는 시간에 따른 IBM Quantum 프로세서의 얽힘 gate 오류율 중앙값을 보여줘요.
이건 로그 스케일이라는 점을 기억해 주세요. 진행 상황이 어느 정도 선형처럼 보이지만 실제로는 훨씬 더 빠른 발전이에요.
마지막으로 속도예요. 이 그래프는 CLOPS라는 지표의 진행 상황을 보여주는데, circuit layer
operations per second의 약자예요. 중요한 건 CLOPS가 circuit 실행 시간과 실시간 및
근실시간 고전 계산 모두를 포괄한다는 거예요. 기본적으로 CLOPS는 프로세서가 특정 circuit을
얼마나 빠르게 연속으로 실행할 수 있는지를 나타내는, 양자와 고전 컴퓨팅을 아우르는 전체 시스템 속도의 척도예요.
현재 녹화 시점에서 IBM은 100 qubit 이상의 기계에 접근을 제공하는 유일한 클라우드 양자 제공업체예요.
몇 슬라이드 전에 말씀드렸듯이, 100 qubit 정도에서 고전 시뮬레이션이
완전히 한계에 다다르기 시작해요. 그래서 이 기계들에서 실행되는 대규모 작업은 고전적인 방법으로는 불가능한 경우가 많아요.
circuit의 일부는 따로 시뮬레이션하는 식으로 활용할 수 있는 미묘함과 요령이 있지만,
일반적으로 이 수치 근방에서 양자 컴퓨터가 고전 컴퓨터로는 할 수 없는 것들을 하기 시작할 수 있어요.
그래서 IBM은 더 큰 기기에 대한 접근을 더 넓은 커뮤니티에 제공하는 것이 매우 중요하다고 결정했어요.
작은 기기에서 하는 건 뭐든 고전적으로 시뮬레이션이 가능해서 양자 우위로 이어질 수 없거든요.
현재 보유한 100 qubit 기기들은 여전히 결함이 있고 노이즈도 많아요. 그래서 작업과
circuit을 실행하는 방법에 대해 현명하게 생각해야 해요. 그냥 circuit을 짜고 shift+enter를 누르는 건
아마 대단한 결과로 이어지지 않을 거예요. 하지만 구현할 수 있는 요령과
모범 사례들이 있어서, 이 기기들에서 더 많은 성능을 뽑아낼 수 있고 그게 더 빨리 양자 우위로 이어지길 바라요.
결함 허용 기계를 계속 개발해 가면서도요. 이 그래프는 고전 컴퓨터와 오류
완화 및 오류 수정이 갖춰진 양자 컴퓨터에서 문제를 푸는 데 드는 시뮬레이션 비용을 보여줘요.
고전 계산 라인은 circuit 복잡도가 커질수록 지수적으로 증가해요.
여기 간단한 circuit에서는 문제없지만, 복잡도가 커질수록 명백히 나빠지는데
시뮬레이션 비용이 아주 빠르게 매우 비싸지기 때문이에요. 오류 완화는 더 잘 확장되니까, circuit 복잡도가
커질 때 우리가 있고 싶은 곳이 여기예요. 현재 고전적 방법과 양자 방법이 일부 응용 분야에서 서로 비슷한 수준에 있어요.
오류 수정이 가장 선호될 수 있고 확장도 정말 잘 되지만,
아직 거기까진 못 갔어요. 그 동안은 오류 완화에 집중하고 가능한 빨리
양자 유용성 영역에 도달하는 것을 목표로 할 거예요. 이 시리즈에서 배울 여러 오류 완화 기법을 활용해서
아주 빠른 시일 내에 양자 유용성을 활용할 수 있는 응용 분야를 찾는 것이 목표예요. 이게
이 강좌의 핵심이에요. 이 기계들이 있고, 정말 흥미로운 연구를 할 수 있다고 생각하는데,
어떻게 활용하면 될까요? 에피소드의 마지막 섹션에서 실용적인 Quantum Computing의 응용 분야에 대해 간략히 얘기해 볼게요.
가장 탐색하고 싶고 양자 유용성을 찾을 수 있을 것 같은 세 가지 주요 분야가 있어요.
첫 번째는 자연 시뮬레이션이에요. 분자나 원자 상호작용 시뮬레이션과 관련이 있고,
재료 과학과 화학 분야에서 매우 중요해요. 앞서 논의한 이유들로 양자
컴퓨터가 고전 컴퓨터보다 이 분야에서 훨씬 뛰어날 거라고 생각해요. 다음은 탐색과
최적화예요. 여기서 주요 알고리즘은 QAOA라고 하는 고전-양자 하이브리드 알고리즘이에요. QAOA는
고전 컴퓨터를 사용해 양자 circuit의 최적 파라미터를 훈련하고 찾아요. 이걸 어느 한 컴퓨터가
혼자 하는 것보다 훨씬 더 효율적으로 할 수 있기를 바라고 있어요. 마지막으로 수학과 구조화된 데이터 처리예요. 양자
컴퓨터는 지저분한 데이터에서 구조를 찾는 데 정말 뛰어나요. 우리나 일반 컴퓨터가 아무것도 못 볼 수 있는
곳에서도요. 양자 머신러닝이 이 분야에서 가능성을 보여주고 있고, 특성
추출과 패턴 인식 같은 작업에 활용하는 걸 목표로 하고 있어요. Quantum Computing 분야에서 일하는 우리에게 정말 흥미로운 시대예요.
역사상 처음으로 고전 컴퓨팅의 영역을 넘어선 컴퓨팅 영역을 탐색하기 시작할 수 있게 됐어요.
이 영상을 보시는 분들은 컴퓨팅 초기 개척자들과 비슷한 역할을 할 수 있어요.
그 개척자들은 앞으로 무슨 일이 일어날지 전혀 몰랐어요. IBM의 T. J. Watson은 심지어 유명하게도 자기 생각엔
전 세계에서 컴퓨터 수요가 두세 대 정도밖에 없을 거라고 말했을 정도예요. 정말 틀렸죠.
우리 모두가 그 초기 컴퓨팅 개척자들과 같은 존재인데, 이번엔 Quantum Computing이라는 새로운 분야에서예요.
양자는 고전 컴퓨팅과 확연히 다른 것으로, 종종 경쟁 관계로 대비되곤 해요.
하지만 이 입문 강의에서 제가 바라는 건, 큰 그림으로 봤을 때 Quantum
Computing은 단순히 긴 계산의 역사에서 다음 챕터임을 납득시키는 거예요. 새로운 계산 방법을 탐구하고
자연 세계의 힘을 활용해 무엇을 할 수 있는지 파악하는 건 인간의 본성이에요. 그리고 우리는
수백 년 동안 그렇게 해왔어요. Quantum Computing은 이 여정에서 새로운 도구를 제공해요. 이 도구가 주는 힘을
어떻게 활용할지 발견하는 건 우리 몫이에요. 시리즈의 다음 강의에서는 100 qubit 시스템에 대해 조금 더 이야기하고,
Qiskit, 즉 저희 양자 소프트웨어 SDK 개요와 지금 이 기계들과 가장 잘 상호작용하는 방법을 알아볼 거예요.
시청해 주셔서 감사해요. 다음에 또 만나요!